ladies and gentlemen from killers of the
flower Moon as William hail Robert
denero
as as Molly Burkhart Lily
[Music]
Gladstone
W as Ernest Burkhart Leonardo
DiCaprio
all
right Lily I'd love to start with you um
in terms of I always like to find out
how you come to a role how does it come
to you was there an audition process was
it a series of
conversations and then the moment you
found out you got the role of Molly what
was that like to you for you and what
did it mean to you I mean from front to
back the whole process was a year and a
half because uh Co shut things down for
a bit there was a major script rewrite
so initially it was a meeting with Ellen
Lewis letting me know that interest was
high but they were going to do a locals
oage casting first which gave me
tremendous faith in the film that that
step was being taken I was found as a
local actor in Montana so that meant
that meant a lot to me actually to hear
um that process happened I was brought
into the room didn't feel great about my
re honestly um I had kind of a hard time
with the the scene as it was written and
come to find it was maybe the one major
scene of um when you get to meet Molly
and Ernest and what their marriage would
have been in that version Co happens I
don't hear anything for8 n months I'm
like keep telling my friends who keep
like insisting that like no no no
they're going to call they're going to
call like no they're not going to call
um and then I was you know biing my time
uh you know the pace of my career has
gone one great India year or one every
two years which you know you need to
find seasonal work in between so I was
registering for a data analytics course
while um and while I was pulling it up
on Shoreline Community College's website
and had my little debit card out and
started getting ready to punch it in
then Skype or not Skype we're we're not
in that age anymore sorry I'm such um I
get a I get a notification that Marty is
requesting a zoom I'm just
like put that credit card back in my
wallet um Marty and I read the scene
about a week later and suddenly it sdes
that I can perform it's like wow this is
really I can take pauses I can like I
can marinate in this a little bit it
felt like the Molly that I'd read in the
book and it felt like something that I
was able to
access did a meet uh did a reading with
Marty and Ellen another week after that
um had a another request for another
Zoom but this time with Leo and Marty
and that was you know the whole time I
had the sides next to me kept
anticipating we would read but we just
talked for like two hours and you were
doing don't look up at the time and like
when we signed off after talking it was
it I think it was over two hours um you
said okay I I'll have a break in my
schedule in the next like two or three
weeks we'll come back and do a chem read
you know cuz it went well and then it's
getting kind of closer to that time I'm
thinking okay 2 3 weeks from now okay
that's December 8th so it's probably
going to be like sometime after that and
then I get a call from both my reps at
the same time which actors know that's a
big deal um on December 1st I'm like oh
time to schedule the chem read and
they're like you got it like wait no no
no no no there's like no you you have it
so I screamed through my phone um
uh saw like you know threw it toward my
dad's Barco lounger I was at home with
my parents in the living room um and uh
noticed a picture of my great grandma
Lily on the mantle like kind of watching
me through the process who would have
been born 10 years after Molly and I'm
like oh
grandma and then for a second I was like
wait it's December 1st i' been doing a
lot of research at that time December
1st nobody designed it this way just
happened maybe one person designed it
this way was um Molly burkart's birthday
oh
wow
Leo you know you're also an executive
producer on this film what did you what
was it that you read or you watched or
conversation that you had where it
clicked for you and you said this is a
project that I want to devote my whole
self
to as soon as I read the book it was a a
lost chapter of of American History um
you know a a horrific time period in in
Oklahoma it was you know right at the
same the reign of terror started the
same year as the Tulsa Massacre the
exact same year so here you had Oklahoma
which was this real hot bed of places
that most indigenous tribes were pushed
onto and you had freed slaves and then
you had the Oklahoma Land Rush and you
had this massive population of white
people reclaiming and taking that land
right back again so 1921 was also so I
think the height of the KKK in in
America and Oklahoma was a hot bed for
that and here you have you know the
onset of uh what was not then the
Federal Bureau of Investigation the
beginnings of the FBI and and Native
American lands were attributed as as as
part of their jurisdiction so we have
this lost chapter of American it was one
of the most fascinating sto American
stories I'd never never heard much like
you know most people hadn't heard about
the Tulsa Massacre and we we kind of
felt this incredible responsibility
immediately to tell this story correctly
that of
course led to you know writing a great
script then we got the we we had an
initial uh screenplay where I was going
to play Tom white we kind of threw that
out we felt that that didn't get to the
heart of the story it didn't get into
the the story the O age frankly it was
uh as Marty talked about it it was an
investigation story it was a who done it
and he kind of wasn't interested in
doing that and there was this small
little section with um with Ernest and
Molly that and we had to read through
and we were like oh my God this is the
emotion of the story this gets us into
the household and here is this very
Twisted bizarre sadistic relationship
between this white man and this oage
woman and this kind of encompasses the
story much better so he went off to do
the Irishman and we kind of said no to
that other script we told the studio
we're not doing it they said okay we're
we're not sure we want to go forth with
it then we got a new studio we did a new
script so it was like a five six year
process of of getting this uh story
correct wow Bob 11th collaboration 10th
10th collaboration with Martin sesi
did you ever think that you know firstly
10 does that surprise
you no I
well looking back on on it in some ways
of course it's all a
surprise but um no I was happy I said
well hopefully we'll get to our
10th project together maybe hopefully
we'll do a few more at what point did
you come to the project and and what was
it that maybe you read or or or why
watched or or spoke about that Drew you
in well I I was told about it and then
Marty was doing it and I read the book
and then and Mar and Leo were doing it
and I and then
um I had committed to it before I even
shot the
Irishman um I said I'm in I'll do it
however I didn't know I I read the book
I didn't know but to the hail character
so that's where it was with me and then
they started telling me that we're going
to change it we have another idea yeah I
I thought that sounds really good too
you know I knew whatever would be with
Marty and and Leo they'd come up with
something very special yeah and it is
very special you know Leo uh I watched
this film again over the weekend and and
the first time I watched it I I loved
your performance and I was like I want
to watch it again I want to see why why
did I love it so much and I think I
loved it because of the versatility
that's in it uh this is a complicated
man he he doesn't just go from bad to
good or good to bad or bad to good to
bad you know he loves his wife he loves
his family but he also has this
commitment to his uncle and who who's
into evil things and you know on on on
the outset he seems like a simple man
but you bring so much complexity to him
and just talk about finding that
complexity in Earnest thank you I you
know I said this the other day but it
was it's kind of like an unreliable
protagonist you know what I mean you you
don't he doesn't even trust himself and
you can't trust him to make the right
decision he's he's not a hero by any
stret of the imagination but in the
research very early on I was struggling
with uh I read a lot of his testimony
and his handwritten letters and you know
by the sheer actions of how easily he
was manipulated by hail I started to
think of him almost like a sort of Lenny
of M men type of character I'm like how
slow could this guy possibly be and even
when he's a writing Molly I mean he
can't form a sentence he's so easily
swayed from you know his his lawyer team
back to the devotion that he's supposed
to have to his wife and his family and
he's just this manipulated uh individual
and so I was struggling with how far to
push that uh but I realized that you
know there's obviously something
incredibly conscious about what he was
doing he was he was playing both sides
of offense and he was doing one of the
most horrific things I could ever
imagine a character doing to his the
person that you know he allegedly loved
and you know there's you know we could
talk about what love means but you know
every every person and every relative
and even people from the oage community
that I spoke to they they insisted that
this was a real love story that there
was a connection between these these two
people they continued to see each other
even afterwards even after the trial but
they had this um this bizarre Dynamic
which was unlike anything I'd ever seen
uh in in cinema history so we when we
were developing the script I said when
when has this been done before and I got
to go see a lot of Montgomery Cliff's
work in A Place in the Sun I was like
wow this narrative has been done before
the the corrosion of the American dream
the the Lust For wealth and and what
what you will sacrifice and the de will
go to in order to achieve that that
became very inspiring then we got to see
Montgomery Clift and um in uh the ays
and uh that helped with the The
Narrative of our relationship as well
and then Red River with John Wayne to
talk about the dynamic between hail and
um and Ernest so all that helped feed us
into trying to tell this this story and
and what this character ultimately was
Lily talk about finding Molly you know I
know you come from black feet Heritage
um how did you kind of tap into your own
experiences in terms of inhabiting her
and and discovering who Molly
was I think what I brought most from
home was um just protocol of how to be
and approaching people about our our
stories cuz I mean Indian Country it's
it's interesting as a native actor a lot
of us have to speak for a character
languages that linguists have deemed
dead languages um I
mean stories like this are an act of
language vitalization so I I I don't
like that term personally but um you
know we're an incredibly diverse group
of people there's 574 federally
recognized tribes in the United States
and another several hundred that are not
um and I mean there's there's linguistic
bases here just like there are you know
Latin languages Germanic languages um
and the difference between Blackfoot
which I speak very little of I can
introduce myself I can count to 10 I
know some animals I know the bad words
um but in any case it gave me like a
process and but it's a very different
cabic system it's very different
um phonetic system and I mean black feet
and no AG it's like difference between
like German and Mandarin you know so it
was it was
um a lot of finding Molly came from the
language and really came from being in
community like I mean I I referenced
that photo of my great grandma Lily on
the wall and I knew I had to approach
Molly the same way I would expect an
actress to approach my grandma with the
same love and care and attention and the
same engagement that my family would
expect to see from her whoever ever she
would be it's like okay that's that's
what I'm tasked with Molly was a real
person and this history is an open wound
for this community that I'm not a part
of um become a part of
in really beautiful wonderful ways but I
think just being back home knowing how
to knowing when you Vis visit Elders you
bring a gift because they're giving you
your time and they're giving you
knowledge so you bring something um
knowing how to sit and be patient and
listen to people talk through these
stories and not be like fact finding but
be absorbing like people share what they
want to share with you so I know how to
sit with people and listen to experience
and all of that came from where I grew
up um my understanding of Molly as this
high like as this woman who you know a
lot
of I I'd written a screen play my senior
year of high school about how my great
grandma Lily met my great grandma
grandpa Alec there were some similar
Dynamics in that marriage that you were
very easy to draw between Ernest and
Molly Alec was an Indian Cowboy but he
was like a very like Lively one you know
a funloving guy and Grandma Lily wanted
to be a nun she didn't want to get
married you know she wanted to be a nun
so she could be a teacher got married
off when she was 16 so but anyways like
the commonality was um Grandma Lily was
when she moved her family to Seattle she
was like the woman all the black feet
all SLE Seattle black feet people will
go visit cuz they said it felt good to
sit and talk Blackfoot cuz she spoke
fluently also a devout Catholic like was
at Sunday Services every weekend when
she when she wanted a parking spot she'd
pull out a rosary and like my dad would
be circling the block and then sure
enough they'd always get a parking
spot um so those things like
relationship to culture language family
um Faith were all very similar to Molly
and just given the fact that they were
born within 10 years of each other so
that had a lot to do
with yeah all of that lent to each other
and then beyond that it was just
bringing the way that my nation's
protocol raised me to be around people
bringing that into another community
that was hosting me and just listening
as best as I
could Bob when I look at some of the
characters you've played from Martin
scusi over the years uh men that are
intimidating men that are violent uh
play by their own rules uh William hail
he kind of comes at you with a smile the
whole time and yet I think he's like the
most Sinister character you've ever
played for Mr squisi uh talk about
finding that Sinister side and
delivering it with a smile the whole
film and who who was this guy well I I I
don't understand him
um I mean I understand what he certain
things like he felt he
was I guess above them he felt part of
the of the uh oage Community but at the
same time uh he learned the language he
he was but he did
uh he also had no problem doing what he
did with uh with with um Lily's
character and and how he manipulated
Leo's character uh that was like a given
you know it was like and some one of the
characters I'm forgetting who says oh
it's an Indian and say oh that's okay
you want to want him to kill him who was
it the attex the great what's his name
uh oh yeah then it's okay you know it's
a different it's a different uh attitude
toward people who are considered in some
ways not people or not your equal to say
the least but below you and they can if
comes to that to have to get the the the
head rights and all that and uh that
they would kill them in in this kind of
more Insidious way blatantly too but
but you know and he felt he was um the
way I I've seen what what he's uh he's
said that they he felt they loved him
you know he was a a respected member of
the Osage Community too or certain parts
of the oage community whether he
actually really believed that I don't
know but it seems like he said he did
and like say he he learn he did know the
language and it's it's look the the
older I get the more I see people that
you know you just you you
don't you just don't know they do things
that you can't comprehend all I know is
I go from A to B to C to D is the
character don't overdo it don't
Telegraph anything don't say I'm a bad
guy or this and that in fact I'm a nice
person you know and part of the
community and everything's okay nothing
wrong you
know that's it and that's how you played
him as a as a nice guy
yeah
okay I mean there were oages that went
to hail's
funeral he wrote them when he was in
prison um I you saw the letters um some
people shared personal family ones that
aren't necess neily easy to find that
hail would write them you know how are
you my friend how's your uncle doing I
miss you I've my new best friend I'm
incarcerated now I did not do this my
new best friend is a sue Indian he's in
here too and just like this man
just and when we got to go to the museum
I mean hail was literally torn out of
these they had these sort of massive
panoramic photos that they did back then
in 1920s and he'd just be torn off the
end he was in most of them but they T I
mean that it it was literally like
watching the scarring that he'd left on
that Community still a 100 years later
and that was what was so you know moving
and and saddening is that you know this
they within the Osage Community this
wasn't talked about so much because of
how horrific it was and how generational
it was and you know we got to meet and
be with you know direct descendants and
relatives of the victims I got to go we
were there a hundred years after the
beginning of the oage reign of terror
the first uh you know Murder of Anna and
100 years later after uh you know the
Tulsa Massacre and the what was it
called not the flower moon but the super
you called it the it was I mean it was
the flower moon but it was also a super
moon which hadn't happened in that
combination ay later since that that day
we shot the the night that you know
Scott Shepard and Cara Jade Meers are
shooting the scene where she's getting
into the car and he's taking her to
whizbang um the night Anam Brown was
murdered was shot 100 years to the day
of when happened that is amazing it was
chilling actually and what was it like
working with the oage and and when you
came to them and approached them about
this uh you know was there convincing I
mean what what what what did they kind
of bring to you that that really helped
open up the story for you um this is I
think think a very important detail and
it also mirrors the film you see that
scene where yansy red corn playing Bon a
castle and ever Waller playing Red Eagle
say are you are you here because of
whatever or is it because we paid you
$20,000 to to be here and do your job um
that was a crucial like element that
removes the whole white saviorism thing
um and also with this film greyhorse
extended an invitation to and the
filmmakers first to come to Fairfax to
um they were going to put food on the
table and just to sit and visit with the
community because they had caught that
the rights had been purchased they knew
the movement they knew that it was going
to happen they knew you know they were
following it pretty much since the book
came out they were following it um so
yeah it was oage who reached out to
Marty and Marty
accepted
that's there are a lot of people that
wouldn't have that would have um had
uh possessive like feelings about the
narrative they wanted to tell you
know like I mean and I know that Leo was
definitely encouraging him to go do that
too and he went and he ate the food he
loves squash that was Marty's favorite
Community watches all those little
things and they remember um yeah yeah
and just to just to add to that you know
you
know I think that um you know it was our
job to listen and it was Marty's job to
listen because as brilliant as David
Gran's book was and it was incredibly
detailed it it didn't specifically have
the oage perspective and there were so
many different elements from the elders
about the specificity of how hard it was
to get the FBI to come and do this job
and then of course bringing this great
actress to my left over here as a
partner in the process she added on so
much detail and soul to Molly but really
shaped The Narrative more from an oage
perspective and you know you begin to
understand that she's really the heroine
of the story she went single-handedly to
Washington brought the funds personally
asked the president it took years and
years and years for the FBI to come
tackle this case you know um so yeah
more than anything it was our job to
hear the oage perspective on this story
because it was so intrinsic to their
culture and has affected them so much
you know multiple collaborations with
Mart sesi between yourself and and Bob
I'd be curious from the both of you what
is something new from this experience
that you learned about your
collaboration that maybe you never saw
before but it came out where on Killers
you going to go first bob up to you up
to
you all right well I'll go I'll go
first no we we Leo and I go back a long
time and um he I don't he joked that
this is just an extension of a movie we
did over 30 years ago This Boy's Life um
but um it was great because Leo has done
six movies this that would have this is
the sixth I've done this is the 10th
we've had a lot of experience all of us
together with him we know each other it
was a very
very nice way to work terrific and uh a
real pleasure um I I just got to say
it's the way they always should be made
for
me um and
um it was just it was perfect actually I
have a thing that I was talking to Leo
the other night about a little bit I
talked to Marty oh we've talked about
this this subject for years
decades and maybe we'll do that movie I
don't know if that'll happen but it
might you never know if we if we can
stay around long enough um anyway but
that's it it's been it was
great so I learned my point is that the
the older I get the more I see things
and and and with us and and the the this
particular project I thought yeah it' be
great if we could get it right but who
knows you know Marty's got other things
and we know we talk but we'll see who
knows that's it yeah six collaborations
what what something new that unlocked in
you for working on that well I I I I
have a tendency to get very sentimental
when I talk about this relationship and
the relationship with Marty because my
career wouldn't have happened without
this man right here he you know kind of
single-handed chose me for my first
starring role and then took it upon
himself to recommend me and say hey
there's this kid you should work with I
just worked with him and I got to work
with Marty a multitude of times but
they've both been like cinematic father
figures to me all the whole generation
of young actors that I grew up with this
was the duo that you spoke about the the
you know the sort of American Treasures
of an actor director CT
relationship that we all aspired to so
to have this 30-year circle of then and
he he says I joke about it but it's true
it was kind of like my character in This
Boy's Life who was an abused stepson
growing up 30 years later it felt so
natural to come back into those shoes
and just become that character but what
was amazing as the work started to
progress was to watch the the
relationship between you know Bob and
Marty and how they work together because
I know how I've worked with Marty over
the years and we flesh things out we
talk about things at Great length but
they have this almost telepathic
communication that's just nods and looks
and then things just start to shift and
it scene changes and it's that's
intrinsic only to a relationship that
could have you know happened you know
how when did you guys meet each other
how how how old were you guys well we
were kids we we didn't know each other
really we'd see each other in the street
and stuff like we had a mutual friend go
back and forth but we started
reconnecting or connect actually
connecting I guess when I was about
27 and um and then talked about um Mean
Streets at that time was called Season
of the Witch and he said we talked that
we had had a frch Christmas
party um and then he said I don't know
if he brought it up then I was telling
him I saw I saw um who's at knocking
with Harvey kitel I said it was great
you know and he knows that world and how
how good it was and how specific it was
and
special uh anyway then this other
project came later he started talking
about that and and uh that's how it
started with us you know again l i I
began with you I want to end with you um
you're sitting between these two legends
here uh talking about history talking
about cinematic rates what's something
knew you learned from each of them about
yourself as a
performer I mean I cut my teeth in
theater and uh can built a career from
independent
film and being the new kid on set um I
think a lot of people in my position and
you know a lot of times it's the first
time you were on set you uh you're like
terrified that you're going to not be
prepared enough um and the theater
training of like okay this is the scene
we're going to play it out from
beginning to end and like go with all
the little things that rise
up I think that lent itself well to a
handful of the things we were doing but
then watching how these two in the
moment will just pull it out of
themselves and like you know if it if it
didn't go the way they wanted no shame
no fear about just like stopping
rewinding and then starting again and
then it's like okay that's okay it's
like maybe the first little run through
was the actor's Discovery and that I
need to go back and tweak that a little
bit and it was so cool to watch that in
person you know there was not a minute
lost watching Bob work it was just he's
he's surgical he goes in camera stays on
him and it doesn't stop until he's done
and he knows what's going to work he
knows what Marty wants he knows what he
wants um so that was that was incredible
to watch him you know it was um I like
okay I don't have to look like I've been
in rehearsal for 3 months walking on set
doing this we
can we can find the truth of it very
very much in the moment and it's film
you know it's it's it's something that
can take a different approach and then
um Leo I just you know it's something I
want to do the next time that I work um
in between every take he would like run
back to the Monitor and watch what he'd
just done and
like you know he was doing the same
thing like you watch Bob do it all from
like you know start start rolling and
then keep rolling until he's got it and
then he's like feel like you need
another one no um and then Leo is um you
know go do one watch it okay I want to
fix this I want to fix this Marty said
this Marty said this and he's very vocal
about it while he's doing it and then we
just keep doing it you know and so it
was nice it was it was very these two
who came up in film you know watching
how that process organically has formed
into the greats of of of the medium you
know um yeah it was it was cool oh and
me talking about things that are
incredible to watch I just want to
congratulate the three of you because it
was incredible to watch all of your
performances in
this
ladies and gentlemen uh the film is
killers of the flower Moon if it means
something to you if you enjoyed it
please tell your friends and family I'm
going to ask everybody to just stay in
your seats for a minute if you can
because uh we have to go somewhere right
away uh but before we do please put your
hands together Leonard DiCaprio willly
Gladstone Robert DeNiro thank you so
much
that